La esclavitud, el tratamiento
de seres humanos
como propiedad privada,
despojados de sus derechos personales,
adoptó muchas formas en todo el mundo.
Pero una institución destaca
tanto por su alcance mundial
como por su perdurable legado:
el comercio transatlántico de esclavos,
que se dio desde finales del siglo XV
y hasta mediados del siglo XIX,
abarcando tres continentes,
y llevando a la fuerza a 10 millones de
africanos a las Américas.
El impacto que esto dejaría no solo
afectó a estos esclavos
y a sus descendientes,
sino también a las economías e historias
de grandes partes del mundo.
Contacto entre Europa y África
hubo desde siempre
a través del Mediterráneo.
Pero el comercio atlántico de esclavos
solo comenzó a finales del siglo XV,
con el asentamiento de colonias
portuguesas en África occidental,
seguido poco después
del español en las Américas.
En las nuevas colonias se cultivaban
caña de azúcar, tabaco y algodón,
cultivos que requerían
mucha mano de obra,
y no había suficientes colonos
o sirvientes contratados
para cultivar todos
aquellos nuevos terrenos.
Se esclavizó a los nativos americanos,
pero muchos murieron por enfermedad,
mientras que otros
se resistieron eficazmente.
Y así, para satisfacer
la gran demanda de mano de obra,
los europeos miraron hacia África.
En África ya existía la esclavitud, una
práctica antigua que adopta muchas formas.
Algunos esclavos eran
sirvientes escriturados
por un tiempo limitado
y podían comprar su libertad.
Otros se parecían más
a los siervos europeos.
En algunas sociedades, los esclavos
podían ser parte de la familia de su amo,
poseían tierra, e incluso
ocupaban cargos de poder.
Pero cuando los barcos mercantes llegaron
ofreciendo bienes manufacturados,
armas y ron a cambio de esclavos,
a los reyes y los comerciantes africanos
tuvieron pocos motivos para dudar.
Ellos vieron a los que vendían
no como compatriotas africanos,
sino como delincuentes, deudores,
prisioneros de guerra de tribus rivales.
Al venderlos, los reyes
enriquecieron sus propios reinos
y los fortalecieron para defenderse
de los enemigos vecinos.
Muchos reinos africanos prosperaron
con la trata de esclavos,
pero la masiva demanda europea
creó una intensa competencia.
La esclavitud reemplazó
otras sentencias criminales,
y la captura de esclavos se convirtió
en una causa para la guerra,
en lugar de su resultado.
Para defenderse de las razias
para la captura de esclavos,
los reinos vecinos necesitaron
armas de fuego europeas,
que también compraron
a la vez con los esclavos.
El comercio de esclavos se había
convertido en una carrera armamentística,
afectando a las sociedades y a las
economías a lo largo del continente.
En cuanto a los propios esclavos, se
enfrentaron a una brutalidad inimaginable.
Después de ser llevados
a fuertes de esclavos en la costa,
afeitados para evitar los piojos,
y marcados como los animales,
eran cargados en barcos
con rumbo a las Américas.
Un 20 % de ellos nunca
volvería a ver tierra firme.
La mayoría de capitanes de entonces
atestaban sus buques,
abarrotando su bodegas
con cuantos hombres pudieran.
Por la falta de higiene
muchos morían o enfermaban
y otros eran arrojados por la borda, por
estar enfermos o como método disciplinario
el capitán aseguraba sus ganancias
al cortar las orejas de sus esclavos
como prueba fehaciente de la compra.
Algunos esclavos tomaron
riendas en el asunto.
Muchos en el continente africano
no habían visto un hombre blanco antes
y llegaron a pensar que eran caníbales,
ya que constantemente se llevaban
gente y regresaban por más.
Por miedo a ser devorados o simplemente
para evitar más sufrimiento,
muchos se suicidaban
o se dejaban morir de hambre,
convencidos de que después de la muerte,
sus almas regresarían a casa.
Los que sobrevivieron, fueron
completamente deshumanizados
y tratados como mercancía.
Las mujeres y los niños
se mantenían en cubierta,
mientras que a los hombres
se les hacía bailar
y sufrían abusos
por parte de la tripulación,
con el fin de mantenerlos
en forma y contener las rebeliones.
Qué pasó con aquellos africanos
que llegaron al Nuevo Mundo
y cómo el legado de la esclavitud
aún afecta a sus descendientes hoy,
es bien conocido.
Pero lo que no se discute a menudo
es el efecto que tendría la trata
de esclavos sobre el futuro de África.
No solo fue que el continente perdiera
decenas de millones de habitantes sanos,
sino que, al ser los hombres
la mayoría de los esclavizados,
el efecto demográfico a largo
plazo fue aún mayor.
Cuando la trata de esclavos fue finalmente
prohibida en las Américas y en Europa,
los reinos africanos cuyas economías
dependían de ello, colapsaron,
dejando la puerta abierta
a la conquista y a la colonización.
Además, el aumento de la competencia
y la afluencia de armas europeas
avivaron la guerra y la inestabilidad
que continúan hasta nuestros días.
El comercio atlántico de esclavos también
contribuyó al desarrollo del racismo.
La esclavitud en África se entendió
como el resultado de un castigo
o la guerra entre tribus,
pero los europeos que predicaban
una religión universal,
y que tenían hace mucho tiempo proscrito
esclavizar a sus hermanos cristianos,
necesitaron una justificación
para una práctica
tan obviamente en desacuerdo
con sus ideales de igualdad.
Así que afirmaban que los africanos
eran seres biológicamente inferiores
y destinados a ser esclavos,
y pusieron mucho empeño
en justificar esta teoría.
Así, la esclavitud en Europa y las
Américas adquirió una base racial,
haciendo imposible que los esclavos
y sus futuros descendientes
pudieran alcanzar el mismo
estatus en la sociedad.
En todos estos aspectos,
el comercio transatlántico de esclavos
fue una injusticia masiva
cuyo impacto continua presente
mucho tiempo después de su abolición.